Bộ tư phát đã chỉ đạo để mạnh chuyên đổi số trong hạt động thí hành án,
sau định ứng dụng công nghệ thông tin là yêu cầu tất yêu,
một trong nghị ưu tốt cứ định sự thêm công của mua hình tổ chức thí hành án mới.
Bối mười hệ thông thông tin,
phân mềm nghiệp vụ đăng được trường khai thực hiện đã mang lại hiệu quả só dễ.
Đến này, phân mềm vũ trở giá quy định thí hành án định từ đã có vình một trăm nghi cứ định được bán hành.
Phân mềm biệt lai định từ đã phát hành trên bố 2018 nghiênh,
tựng số tiền gần 2018 nghiênh 4 xam sống mới tì đồng.
Thì đềm người thông báo thí hành án dân sự cho đường sự quả ứng dụng viên ía đi,
với một nghiênh tâm trong bệm miệm hai lợt tại thành phố Xí miệng.